and could playing video games help with
ADHD a clinical trial is underway right
here in Las Vegas to determine that
determine the outcome doctors at the
center for Psychiatry and Behavioral
Medicine in Las Vegas are testing out a
video game-like application in hopes
that it will improve attention they're
also conducting another clinical trial
this for a non-stimulant medication and
now they're looking for participants who
either have attention deficit disorder
or think that they may have it
by studies pay for people to come in
they pay for time and effort our first
visit they get about a thousand dollars
worth of free medical care because we do
blood work and we do physicals and we
take a good medical history we make sure
we take their vital signs
well the trials are open to everyone
from kids to adults but you cannot have
many health problems due to concerns
that other medications could interfere
with the drug that they're testing you
cannot also also you cannot use
marijuana contact the center for
Psychiatry and Behavioral Medicine if
you're interested now